(intriguing music)
- [Narrator] Deep in the protected
river lands of Guizhou, China,
a forest ranger has forged
a special relationship
with some of the rarest
monkeys in the world.
(foreign language)
Xiao is tasked with
monitoring the monkeys.
It has taken decades of patience
to build a mutually trusting
relationship with them.
(foreign language)
Over the past 20 years,
Xiao has become an expert
in the group's rituals and behavior
and has given scientists unique
insight into the species.
(foreign language)
Under his care, Xiao has
seen the number of his group
increase, but the species
remains endangered.
(foreign language)